mais françois cocq essayiste pour réagir
justement à cette cérémonie inédite du
14 juillet françois cocq bonjour merci
d'être en direct sur rtl france un
honneur un hommage par don symbolique
justement aux soignants mais aussi à
toutes les personnes qui ont participé à
la lutte contre le coronavirus est-ce
que ce geste symbolique est à la hauteur
des enjeux qui secoue actuellement le
service public de santé
écoutez c'est bien le moins que
pouvaient faire les cas en terme de
reconnaissance vis-à-vis de toutes
celles et tous ceux qui ont lutté et qui
ont finalement été les premiers de
corvée et qui ne se sont pas défilés
contrairement à beaucoup dans la crise
que nous avions que nous avions devant
nous et pour autant on voit que loin du
faste et de l'objet communicationnel qui
est présenté par à part monsieur macron
avec ce défilé du 14-juillet bien
finalement le peuple et toutes celles et
tous ceux qui ont la tâche aujourd'hui
de reconstruire le pays s'organisent par
eux mêmes et je note que là où monsieur
macro célèbre par exemple les armées
pour la porte qui a été apportée pendant
là pendant la crise dont on peut se
demander s'il était légitime et
finalement si utile je pense notamment
au rapport des sapeurs pompiers
utilisaient que certaines opérations qui
avaient été organisés avec l'armée pour
des transports de patients étaient plus
des opérations de communication qu'est
réellement utile et bien à côté de ces
célébrations là il ya une célébration
populaire celle des soignants qui
s'organise qui a eu lieu ce matin dans
les différentes préfectures de nos
départements qui aura lieu cet après
midi à paris entre république et
bastille et finalement le peuple se
prend en main à côté du spectacle qui
est donné aujourd'hui
vous savez une célébration a toujours un
objet est celle du 14 juillet
normalement elle célèbre l'union du
peuple
elle célèbre sa capacité à se forger et
abattre l'arbitraire c'est c'est le
symbole de la prise de la bastille vous
savez qu ont célébré le 14 juillet au
départ au chant du ça ira
celui qui lie à ça ira ça ira l'égalité
partout règnera eh bien on va
aujourd'hui la situation post coït
d'ailleurs qui n'est pas du tout une
situation post coït quand on regarde la
situation sanitaire aujourd'hui et bien
cette situation là n'est pas une
situation où les gagne l'égalité est
mise sur le devant de la scène et au
contraire monsieur macro entend sans
servir pour aller plus loin que loin
dans son projet de déstructuration de
l'idéal républicain
justement on sait que des manifestations
vont avoir lieu cet après midi le
personnel de santé qui n'est pas
totalement satisfait par le ségur de la
santé certains voient cet hommage comme
une provocation face à ces
revendications salariales mais également
l'amélioration des conditions de travail
porté depuis des années ce que vous
partagez cet avis bien sûr puisque il
est fait le sel de ce qui aujourd'hui
nous disent que il faut aider l'hôpital
aidé le service public ont beau jeu de
dire quand dès que nous ne sommes pas
dans une situation de crise
il en profite pour tailler dans les
effectifs pour déstructurer
l'organisation du service de soins pour
le libéraliser le livrer à la
concurrence et aux et au privé est donc
aujourd'hui on voit l'état dans lequel
se situe notre service de santé et
celles et ceux qui se battent pour
l'améliorer comme ils ont été aux côtés
de toutes celles et tous ceux qui
étaient malades est victime de la crise
il ya quelques semaines de cela ont
raison de dire que finalement ils ont
été méprisés pendant des années et
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas une médaille en
chocolat dont ils ont besoin mais il
demande simplement à pouvoir faire
correctement leur travail dans les
meilleures conditions
finalement c'est ça que l'état devrait
apporter plus tôt que des parades qui
elles ne servent que de communication
politicienne pour le président de la
république alors le président de la
république qui va s'adresser aux
français qui va répondre aux questions
des journalistes
dans peu de temps est ce que là aussi
vous y voyez une opération de
communication de la part du chef de
l'état ou entente il vraiment relancer
la fin de son quinquennat
je ne doute pas qu emmanuel macron en
organisant cette interview en revenant à
l'interview du 14 juillet et quelques
id électoralistes en tête preuve en est
le choix qui a été fait par lui et par
ses équipes de celles et ceux qui vont
interviewer madame salamé monsieur
boulot qui ne sont jamais rien d'autre
que les caniches médiatique du pouvoir
et qui vont donc servir la soupe à
monsieur à monsieur macro mais si
monsieur macron avait de réelles
préoccupations il s'intéresserait à ce
qui se passe réellement dans le pays ce
qui se passe dans le pays aujourd'hui
c'est que le 9 juillet nous avions 5 166
nouveaux cas d'infection au coronavirus
autrement dit nous sommes revenus à des
chiffres qui sont ceux de début juin ils
sont en constante augmentation
a marseille le nombre de nouveaux cas
d'où le poulet deux jours et qu'a fait
monsieur macron il ya tout juste une
semaine
il a remplacé monsieur philippe par
monsieur castex là encore dans une
opération purement politiciennes en
enlevant le monsieur déconfinement de
son rôle et en faisant finalement une
forme de nouvelles buzyn c'est à dire
que quelqu'un qui en place dans un
secteur clé et stratégiques à un moment
donné où la crise se joue est retiré de
son poste pour mener une opération
politicienne et électoraliste et bien je
crois que monsieur makonda finalement
que bien peu au coeur l'avenir de notre
pays et la santé des françaises et des
français et qu'ils aient tous projetés
effectivement vers les élections de 2022
il faudra se souvenir de ces épisodes
au moment de mettre un bulletin dans
l'urne comment est ce que vous voyez la
fin du quinquennat d'emmanuel macron
c'est que voilà ça va être la première
fois que le chef d'état s'exprime depuis
le remaniement ministériel
dans quelques jours ce sera au tour de
jean castex de présenter
son discours de politique générale celui
qui va suivre en tout cas le plan qu'il
doit suivre pour les années à venir en
tout cas pour les deux ans qui restent à
emmanuel macron au pouvoir la stratégie
de monsieur leproux semble clair son
nouveau chemin n'est jamais que la
perpétuation de l'ancien pour preuve les
équipes qu'il a été la mise en place à
la fois monsieur castex mais aussi les
ministres il a fait enlever les
incompétents notoires mais c'est
castaner madame b to b m'aide à me
pénicaud mais il a maintenu les
idéologues monsieur le maire monsieur
darmanin monsieur blanc caire et les
autres autrement dit ceux là vont avoir
pour mission d'aller au bout de la tâche
de libéralisation de l'état qui va se
faire sur le dos des français et c'est
une stratégie du choc que monsieur
macron veut mettre en place qui va
arroser et saupoudrée d'une part de
retour à l'ordre et ce faisant il va
vouloir capter l'électorat de la droite
et rejouer le match de 2010 est face à
face à madame le pen sauf que on voit
bien que tout cela n'est jamais que de
la politique fiction le monde réel n'est
pas celui là vous aurez noté les
enquêtes d'opinion qui nous disent laon
ce mois de juin et de juillet que les
intentions de vote des françaises et des
français pour 2022 sont exactement les
mêmes que celles qui étaient donnés en
octobre dernier autrement dit avant la
réforme de retraite par exemple avant la
crise du cornât virus et ses enquêtes
n'ont pas du tout bougé de même que le
résultat des municipales a finalement
laissé un équilibre entre les grands
blocs comme nous l'avions connu en 2014
ce que je veux dire c'est que la
situation actuelle la réalité du pays
la réalité de notre quotidien n'a pas
aujourd'hui encore à infuser sur la
scène politique parce que celle ci est
complètement verrouillé mais cela ne
pourra pas aller jusqu'en 2022 est
forcément 2022 va être le moment d'un
basculement nous ne rejoueront pas en
le match de 2010 est tout simplement
parce que les françaises et les français
ont dit à l'occasion du premier et
surtout du second tour des municipales
qui ne voulait plus participer à cette
mascarade avec toutes celles et tous
ceux qui corsètent est la vie
démocratique et finalement qui capte le
pouvoir à notre détriment
merci beaucoup françois copt d'avoir
réagi sur votre antenne je rappelle que
vous êtes essayiste